much is being made particularly by
right-wing media about an utterance that
President Joe Biden made yesterday which
some are saying is a sign that he is not
planning to run for re-election in 2024.
now there's been a lot of attention on
the Republican side over the last
several weeks the reason for that
attention has been that failed former
president Donald Trump announced he's
running again despite that Ron DeSantis
the recently re-elected governor of
Florida is polling really well even
though he hasn't actually announced that
he's running for anything the Republican
Civil War Etc so there have been a lot
of reasons why the focus has been on the
Republican side but there's another
element to this which is that the
suspicion that Joe Biden is not really
interested in running for re-election
has been to some degree supplanted by
the growing belief that Joe Biden will
run for re-election and polling that
looks pretty okay for Joe Biden and
suddenly headlines like this one
appeared yesterday
for example in the right-leaning
Washington examiner I don't know about
that Biden casts doubt on 2024 run so
what exactly happened well let's just
look at the video what you are going to
see here is Joe Biden delivering a
statement at the White House a tribal
Nation Summit and as he is wrapping up
someone from the crowd seems to shout
out four more years and Joe Biden seems
to respond I don't know about that
that's the best assessment that we have
although it's not totally clear let's
take a look at it and then discuss
as my grandfather finding him and say
that's the Irish of it thank you all
very much
okay four more years I don't know about
that
so is that what was said it seems to be
I mean I think I heard four more years
and then I don't know about that let's
listen to it one more time I think I'm
gonna say that's the Irish of it thank
you all very much
thanks oh I don't know about that
is too much being made of this I think
so I don't have any special insight into
whether Joe Biden is or isn't going to
run if you had asked me nine months ago
I would have said I think Joe Biden is
definitely not running for re-election
today I think it's much more likely that
he will run for re-election and part of
this has to do with legislative
achievements uh approval rating recovery
circumstantial elements to this there's
a lot of different reasons but I'm
separating my opinion from what we saw
there I think it is just as likely
as what Joe Biden meant was
this isn't the venue in which we're
going to talk about my campaign because
we're here for the tribal Nation Summit
that would be consistent with Joe
Biden's personality and his kind of
modus operandi
um I think it's just as likely that it's
that as it is Joe Biden saying I don't
know that I'm going to be running and in
fact when you really think about it is
it likely that Joe Biden would let slip
arguably for the first time in a more
formal capacity that he might not run in
response to an utterance from the crowd
at an event about something completely
different I don't think so if Joe Biden
is going to tell us I don't know that
I'm running in 24 I don't think it's
going to be in a venue like this in
reaction to something yelled out from
the crowd now when it comes to the
polling question it is interesting to
take a look at some of the relatively
new polling that we have seen
um for 2024 these are of course
hypothetical polls and it's really a
pretty mixed bag here you see that an
Emerson College poll that's an A minus
rated pollster has it as Biden DeSantis
DeSantis plus four but in Biden versus
trump it has it even uh on the other
hand you look at the Marquette
University law school poll also that's
an A B rated pollster pretty good they
have Biden even with DeSantis
um in one poll
um DeSantis slightly ahead in a
different poll and then Biden well ahead
of Donald Trump and then you go back to
a premise poll not a rated pollster at
all they have DeSantis plus four over
Biden but Biden plus six over Trump so
the gist of the polling right now
contains two pieces of important data
number one against Trump Biden seems to
pull pretty well
and against DeSantis Biden polls less
well that's the trend and depending on
which poll you look at the specific
numbers differ
we are going to have to wait and see I
don't know what Biden heard in the
moment I don't a hundred percent know
what Biden said
but I don't believe Biden would reveal
possibly not running in that sort of
venue and in that sort of format
one of our sponsors is all form the
easiest way to design your own custom
sofa I have one from all form unlike
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape color even
the color of the legs I have not one but
two all form sofas I've had them for
years they look good as new definitely
the most comfortable Furniture I own and
it gets even cooler because all form
sofas are completely modular you can buy
a sofa and if you move you can adapt it
to the new space by adding on to it or
rearranging its elements that is
definitely not something you get from
your typical Sofa Company all form has
everything from eight piece sectionals
to love seats and arm chairs everything
is made in the USA using premium
materials all form makes sure that
assembly is really easy I didn't even
need any tools which is good because I
have very few tools and you can keep the
sofa for over three months and send it
back free if you don't like it for a
full refund right now all form is giving
my audience 20 off all orders at
allform.com Pacman the link is down
below